اكتشفت ثلاث شابات بوب
أنهن جميعًا يواعدن نفس الرجل في
نفس الوقت
الذي يُزعم فيه أن الرجل كان يواعد ثلاثة
آخرين بالإضافة إلى ستة أشخاص آخرين ،
لكن آبي بيكا ومورجان
أصبحوا أصدقاء في النهاية
وهم ينطلقون الآن في
حافلة مدرسية تم تجديدها  لقد تحدثوا إلى سوزان
هندريكس
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع حول هذا الأمر ،
وأعتقد أنه عندما التقينا في البداية كان من
الواضح أننا نقرنا جيدًا حقًا
وبعد ذلك
خلال عملية البناء ، أعتقد
أننا جميعًا ندرك أن
هذا ممكن كما نحب جميعًا
بعضنا البعض لم نواجه أي مشاكل حتى الآن
ولكنك تعلم أننا فقط بعد ثلاثة
أسابيع بالطبع لقد تخلصوا من المتأنق حسنًا ، لذا
فقد ألهمت قصتهم أشخاصًا آخرين
لاتخاذ القفزات التي حصلنا عليها
من الأشخاص الذين يشاركونهم
القصص والقول بأنك يا فتيات ألهمتني
بأنك تعيشين أحلامك كما لو كنت
أريد أن أعيش أحلامي ،
نحن فخورون جدًا بكم يا رفاق لعدم
التركيز على السلبيات وتحويل
هذا إلى شيء إيجابي
كأننا بكينا جميعًا كما لو أنه كان أمرًا
لا يُصدق الأشخاص الذين
تواصلوا معهم ونعم تمامًا
كما لو كان هناك الكثير من الحب الكثير
من الجميع ،
لذا فقد أطلقوا على رحلتهم اسم حافلة بام
بعد الأحرف الأولى
في كل من أسمائهم